in 2011 a total of 97 politicians in the  UK were asked a maths problem if you  spin a coin twice what is the  probability of getting two heads  this solution is straightforward the  sample space of flipping two coins has  four equally likely outcomes  hht th and TT there's exactly one  outcome of two heads and so the  probability is one over four or twenty  five percent  in spite of 77 percent of the  politicians saying they were generally  confident with numbers the problem  stumped the majority of the group only  40 percent gave the correct answer  this is a troubling situation but it's  also an opportunity watching online  educational videos even a short one like  this is a proven way to improve your  skills so keep watching and sharing and  hopefully soon everyone will be solving  simple problems like this in their heads  from the thumbnail